yesterday we had a deposit flight back
into the Greek banking sector seven
hundred million to be precise 700
million euros came back to the bigger
banking sector as a result of the the
news of this bridge of game in the four
month and I haven't checked the numbers
today but I'm sure that is continued
today you're still down however by tens
of billions it's a question of direction
as you know once you turn the tide you
hope so mark the tide has already been
stem deposits are flowing back into the
Greek banking system how long will this
last and will they be able to make up
the tens of billions that have flown out
remains to be seen but this is a very
positive sign mark at work there's no
new money in the bailout extension for
Greece is that going to be a problem
well it could very well be a problem and
as soon as next month mark and that is
because Greece is running out of money
doesn't have enough money to pay its
bills it needs to pay government
salaries it needs to make government
pensions and it needs to make a payment
to the IMF in March so I said to mr.
varoufakis aren't you at risk of running
out of money you aren't going to be in a
position to ask the IMF or to ask your
eurozone partners for some kind of a new
bailout let's say until at least june
until this four-month extension is over
mr. VAR Farkas said there are several
ways in which perhaps reese's partners
as he puts them or the institutions the
ECB the IMF and the European Commission
might be willing to work with Greece
between now and then to help it pay its
bills here is Yanis varoufakis
explaining what he means by that the ECB
could simply hand over this money to the
IMF as partial payment on behalf of the
Greek government since the ECB
recognizes that this is money that we're
old and this is money that is not
borrows money it's money that is our
money another payment to the ECB why not
simply have the two institutions find
its amongst themselves
find the Muslims way of transferring
this for these funding